[Music]
thank you all for coming and thanks to
the organizers for inviting me but not
only that also having drinks after my
talk which means that we have an
audience I'm very very grateful for that
I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about this mysterious mysterious thing
called a plant Factory and why why I'm
so interested in in it and why I think
at some point maybe this is going to
touch your lives as well so let's start
with an introduction this is me by the
way engaging in what our farmers like to
call fake farming so if you do this this
is usually when people want to take some
promotional pictures of you and you go
to the farm and you touch the plants a
little bit with gloves of course very
very very clean and then a farmer which
you can see in the picture will shout a
farmer at you from the back but this is
how did I end up here well I started
kind of a strange meandering through the
disciplines I started at physics more
and more theoretical ended up getting a
PhD in Applied Mathematics a very
natural switch from that I would say to
data science where I worked at several
companies and ended up in farming of
course natural where I'm the operations
data science so I'll explain a little
bit what that means so what we are is an
indoor vertical hydroponic farm so it's
vertical because that way you can put it
near cities it's very efficient with
space and hydroponic means it's soil
free and there are other efficiencies
that come with that but why are we why
do we think that this is necessary well
pretty soon we're going to have a lot of
people on this earth and they all need
to eat and most of them live in urban
areas or will be living in urban areas
because that's a pattern that we see and
in order to feed all these people
we're going to have to produce a lot of
food and the challenge with that is that
already
our agricultural industry is using 70%
of the freshwater that we use it's going
there and it has other impacts on our
planet that are just not sustainable so
we need to somehow reduce the footprint
whilst growing much much more so our
goal is of course to produce more food
that is healthy that we can save water
and maybe have less footprint in other
ways and protect our natural
environments so the way we want to solve
this is by growing near cities don't use
any pesticides at all use a lot less
water that's what the hydro mix is for
without soil means you don't have to use
as much water because there's less
evaporation and we want to sell fresh
produce that can be sold much closer to
the day of harvest so also you can
produce food waste that way so how do we
increase our outputs and at the same
time reduce our footprints well we have
to we have to scale and in order to
scale we have to automate so one model
in which this has of course happened
before is when factories were introduced
so this is a way in which you can get
raw materials in a lot of automation
happens in the mean time and the
finished product is much faster to
produce it's much less expensive to
produce of course and it's of reliable
quality so in our case plant Factory is
something that takes in some raw
materials and outputs these products and
may I say these products are actually
you can already buy them in supermarkets
unfortunately for you you'll have to fly
all the way to the States for that so I
don't recommend it at the moment until
we come here because yeah that's not
very energy efficient but an important
feature of our plant Factory is that it
is seasonless so you know of course
people like to buy seasonal food
good because that's also more
energy-efficient but in our case we are
trying to separate the seasonality from
it and produce things in a controlled
environment that we can grow efficiently
at any time of year with a lot more
yield per square foot in an automated
way and something that I'll explain
later
in a smart way so what is this smart
farming
well it means controlling our
environment in a very very precise way
that that's just not possible if you do
it outside so you can have lights not
just intensity but also schedule you can
vary the temperature you can have wind
blowing or knots you can have irrigation
schedules and of course plant food that
you change you can change the
composition of the air that flows around
and you don't just you don't just
control all these things you want to
also know everything about these plants
so what you see here in the bottom is a
video of on the Left we're just filming
our crops and on the right you see a
computer vision model that is estimating
what its plant mass and what isn't and
on the bottom what you see is our
estimate of the canopy area which we can
use to predict yield so there are many
more things of course that we can do we
can check for disease and all sorts of
things that is much more efficient if a
computer vision algorithm does its
versus humans looking at all these
images but what's also very important is
how we combine these two things so here
you you have these two very automated
pieces but the third thing is using them
and using the fact that we can grow much
more quickly and that we can know
everything about them and that we can
control everything about them to have
very short experimental cycles so we
grow something every day a new
experiment starts we start growing
something we very precisely control how
we grow it according to what we call a
recipe which basically states
this many days under this much light at
this temperature with this irrigation
everything and we measure what happened
to it whether we actually managed to
stick to the recipe and then we know we
can analyze all that data and that's an
experiments and this is experimentation
at scale so how do we actually make this
possible because we're not an Research
Institute we're actually a business
we're in the business of selling all
this crop we are learning in the process
but we also want to sell crop and so the
way we do this is by having a smart
supply chain and that's what I work on
in operations so our supply chain looks
pretty much like this we plan it's
always good to have a plan we see it
according to the plan all the little
crops go into the grow room where they
have these controlled environments at
some point we harvest them we pack them
and ship them to our customers and we
try to analyze and forecast what the
orders are going to be so we can plan
again etc but every every of these steps
a human can do a simple version but we
can make all these steps more efficient
and smarter so let's focus on one and
that's crop placements because we want
to make sure that we are very efficient
with our resources but also that our
crops have the follow the recipe and
that they have the right environment so
we know from our positions a lot so
every every of these positions are not
the same they're not identical positions
next to each other can have different
airflow different temperature all sorts
of things so that's apart from the
things you can control there's also of
course features of the space and we can
measure all these things very precisely
but also from our crop we know a lot of
very precise things like some wants to
have a night time maybe some don'ts
maybe some you can grow much more
quickly by just having it be Dale all
the time
and yeah maybe some don't want to be
near each other maybe they're somehow
affecting each other maybe one would
block the air to the other or maybe
they'd spread diseases to each other
some might be want to be in the heat
some might be actually growing faster
than we expect so we need to change our
schedule to accommodate that and maybe
one is looking a little stressed so you
might want to have changes in the
schedule as as a prop starts to look
stressed and we want to move to another
schedule so this kind of problem is just
matching these crops to positions which
you can see as a bipartite graph where
the nodes on the weather on the one hand
are our crops and on the other hand are
the positions and we want to minimize a
cost of using resources placing crops in
the wrong environments or being
inefficient in in other ways so what we
want to find is a matching between all
our crops and these positions and the
actual solution looks like an assignment
made matrix so you can assign crop a to
position one for example etc etc and
this is going to be quite a sparse
matrix and this kind of problem is
called a discrete optimization problem
so this sort of problem is very common
in manufacturing and scheduling for
instance and in this case I've used
Google or our tools to solve it but
there are many other solvers out there
this is a very convenient sort of
package to start with
so let's look in this case what kind of
constraints we might have so there are
some obvious constraints namely you
cannot put two crops in the same
position well that one should be pretty
obvious and you can see that that's in
our matrix means that we have a row that
sums up to more than one
another constraint is of course we want
to match all of our crops we don't want
to just leave them out there so if you
have a column that is all zeros that is
also not a good thing but you will see
it's perfectly fine to have rows that
are all zeros that just means we leave a
position empty so here you can say all
right how do I solve this all right I I
make it a feasible problem I move I move
one crop from one position to another
one and I just assign one random
position to the missing one but this is
not a very efficient solution you can
see there's two open spots there so you
might want to move those other two crops
in there possibly but this is of course
a very very simplified version I haven't
used any of the data I showed you and
you can see maybe that there's a lot of
combinatorics involved here so the
problem gets more and more complex so
here and here there's different ways you
can go about making this better you can
just you can try to be very efficient or
you can try to be very expressive and it
depends a little bit on your problem
which you want to be so a cost adding a
cost means you're more expressive so in
the real world things aren't really
constraints except for the overfilling
like you can't put two things in the
same spots but many other things are not
really constraint you can just model
them as maybe a very high cost so maybe
you don't want to exclude all
possibilities if it's entirely possible
that it could be even the best solution
because it outweighs a lot of other
costs but on the other hand constraints
do make your model a lot more efficient
so very often if you if you look at so
our scale of firms is pretty huge so
that means that all these solutions are
going to be like very hard to compute so
having all these complex costs instead
of constraints is going to be maybe not
the ideal
ideal thing to do especially in a farm
in which situations change all the time
and you don't want to have two hours of
computing computation time for a two
minute decision
so the yeah so let's take that approach
for now and say why what if we want to
find one part of the solution which we
want to simplify and one way you can
simplify a combinatorial optimization
problem is by exploiting symmetry you
never want to have a problem that has
symmetry because if if there is one
option and this option and they're
actually the same from a cost
perspective then you have done too much
computation so in this case you could
say well simpler crops go to similar
positions and I'm only matching just the
groups together but this makes of course
an assumption maybe you don't you don't
want to treat the similar crops the same
maybe you want to run an experiment on
them so I've told you a lot about
combinatorics and optimization or a
little bit in any case but where's the
AI in this whole story well it's pretty
much everywhere so for example let's
look at the planning and the seeding
there's a lot of there's a lot of
machine learning that can go into
forecasting for example on the right
side we have the most information
because on the sales side well we have a
bit less influence but on the right side
we have all these sensors so for example
the computer vision I told you about and
all the other sensors so we could use AI
to to to help us predict a few things
there but actually a reality when a lot
of things change and you're not really
at steady state yet human partnerships
are actually really useful just
utilizing human predictions in a way
that you can later replace them with an
automated predictor is it's a very
efficient way to scale so you start by
replacing something like computer vision
which is really hard for human and only
at the end you start replacing other
things so our partners in the supply
chain and what we what they care about
our agricultural science they care a lot
about whether we comply to recipes but
also they want us to search recipe space
so if we're doing really well in ER in
our production and we're definitely
gonna make our orders they want us to
explore a little bit more the recipe
space automation and robotics they care
mostly of course about mission time they
don't want the automation to have to do
too many things if not necessary
operations care mostly about efficiency
there so process flow supply chain they
care about putting most as much as much
of the harvest as possible towards
orders and not waste anything but they
can help us as well so agricultural
science can tell us well if you mess a
little bit up in the lighting that's
fine you can make it up later or if you
want to make sure you irrigate well make
sure you focus on the first few days
those are the most important and for
example automation can give us maybe
outside the box solutions so we come up
with a recommendation we notice that
they tend to do things a little bit
differently and we can just ask them
about it and say alright how would you
solve this as a human operations can of
course foresee issues with labor or they
can maybe see that some machines are
being used a lot one part of the day and
then not use later so maybe we should
adjust our schedules and supply chain
can do order forecasting very well
obviously because sales people affect
the thing that we're predicting so
naturally we should ask them first so
one final piece of advice I always say
just like test-driven development we
should actually be doing reporting
driven automation so
we first want to report on the thing
that we're trying to improve on and make
sure that we understand all the KPIs
that we are trying to hit before before
we actually write a single line of code
so one reason is of course we know what
the baseline is and we know whether
we're actually improving but this can
also give us hints towards a solution
maybe we thought about treating it as an
optimization discrete optimization
problem but maybe it's actually another
another way and finally reporting can
also mean that you write reporting tests
so maybe if they if somebody doesn't use
your recommendations you want to be
alerted you want to ask them why and you
want to learn from that and of course
you have to make a lot of simplifying
assumptions to even be able to solve all
these problems so you want to report on
whether these or alerts when any of
these assumptions fail and finally let's
end on a on a wiser wise quote and this
is something I say well pretty much
every day it is very hard to automate
the changing process basically you have
to write a solution and it's going to
get more and more complex and you have
to be willing to just throw it all in
the bin
very quickly because when the underlying
processes change automation can be can
be a bit of a challenge and on that note
I would like to thank you
[Applause]